تزوج كارلوس وجريس مونيز هذا الأسبوع
في مستشفى ميثوديست في سان أنطونيو حيث كان
كارلوس
منذ دخوله مصابًا بفيروس كورونا
في الخامس عشر من يوليو ،
بعد أيام قليلة من دخوله المستشفى ، ساءت حالة كارلوس
وتم نقله إلى العناية المركزة
قبل وضعه
في المستشفى.  ecmo شكل من أشكال دعم الحياة جيدًا ،
خمن جيدًا ما الذي انضم إلي الآن
كارلوس وجريس مونيز شكرًا
جزيلاً لكما حقًا أقدر
انضمامكما
إلينا أم كارلوس ، سأبدأ معك
أولاً أنت هناك في المستشفى ولكن
الآن أنت '  مرة أخرى ، تهانينا للزواج ، كيف
يجعلك
ذلك تشعر مع كل ما تمر به ، أنا
كامل تمامًا في الوقت الحالي ، أنت تعلم
أنني تمكنت من رؤية النعمة عدة
مرات ، لقد تمكنت من القدوم
ورفع معنوياتي فقط  بالإضافة إلى النعمة ،
تهانينا
لك أيضًا ، أعلم أنه لم يكن اليوم
الذي خططت له ، لكن
يمكننا أن نرى من الصور أنه كان
جميلًا ، يرجى إخبارنا عنه ،
انظر يا إلهي ، يا إلهي ، ما هي العروس الجميلة
التي كانت تعمل  لقد كان الأمر مثاليًا للغاية ،
لقد كان أكثر مما يمكن أن
نطلبه عندما ذكروا ذلك
لنا أنهم يستطيعون آه
بشكل أساسي أننا كنا نتحدث إلى
ممرضته مات وسألني كم من الوقت
كنا متزوجين
ولم أستطع  أكذب عليه وأخبرته
أننا حصلنا على الشهادة ،
ولم يكن لدينا توقيعات ،
وقد بدأ للتو في التحضير لحفل الزفاف
وفي غضون
دقائق مثل عاد وقال إنه
يمكننا الزواج منك يوم الثلاثاء ،
لذلك أنا كذلك  أنا مندهش من السرعة
التي تحركوا بها واتصلوا بي
وسألوني عن الألوان
التي اخترناها ولديهم أزهار
لديهم كعكة ،
أعني أنهم زينوا سريره ووضعوا
العلب في ظهر سريره وهم
يتدحرجون  في
ذلك قال فقط تزوجت للتو ، لذا فقد
كانت مجرد لحظة خاصة جدًا بالنسبة
لنا وبصراحة اعتقدت أنهم
سيسمحون لنا فقط بالقيام بالحفل
لم أكن أعرف أنهم سيفعلون كل
ذلك
ولكنهم حتى  webex لعائلتنا
وأصدقائنا للانضمام
لذلك كان الأمر كذلك  فريق عمل مدهش
مذهل مدهش يعمل هناك في
تلك الوحدة المرغوبة في
قسمين جنوبيين ، أعطني أنتم وأعطوني صوتًا ،
شكرًا لك على منح الأمل لك كارلوس الذي
تعرفه ،
أعلم أنك كنت في المستشفى لقد
مر وقت عصيب.
تأكد من أن هذه الشفتين تساعد في رفع معنوياتك
ويمكنني فقط أن أقول إنني أعرف كل شخص في جميع أنحاء
هذا البلد ، وكل من
يشاهده يصلي من أجلك ماذا تريد أن
تقول لشعب أمريكا الآن
فقط كن مدركًا ، اجعل نفسك مدركًا
للعذر ، اجعل نفسك على علم  من
الأشياء التي يمكن أن تحدث
مع الكورونا ، ارتدي أقنعةك
بالتأكيد تعلم أن يديك
نظيفة ، فأنت تعرف المسافة الاجتماعية بقدر
ما يمكنك
اتباع إرشادات ولاياتك
وما لديهم من أجلك
لأن هذا هو أصعب شيء.
ما فعلته في حياتي
وهو ما يغير حياتي فهو حقًا
مجرد
تبرع بالبلازما إذا كان لديك
مصحف وإذا كنت قد تعافيت
فلديك هذا الخيار لتكون قادرًا على الحصول
على البلازما لتتمكن من إعطائها
الأجسام المضادة
وهذا ما كان اختيارًا بالنسبة لي في
الواقع ، كان علي الانتظار لمدة خمسة أيام
بسبب العرض
وقد ساعدني بشكل كبير
ولكن حتى بعد ذلك أنت تعرف فقط
الطاقم الطبي
وكل شخص هنا قام
بعمل رائع
من  من الاعتناء بي جيدًا ، نريد
أن نمنحك فترة راحة ونتأكد من
تعافيك ولكن
شكرًا للأمل وحياة طويلة وسعيدة
لكليكما ، حسنًا ، تهانينا